here's a report from well Andy note
tweeted this out says breaking leftist
journalist and activist Josh Krueger has
been tragically shot dead at his
Philadelphia home Krueger has long
downplayed gun violence in his City and
publicly chastised others who spoke
about it
so that's the story and uh you know it
was going viral last night that this guy
who I'd never heard of but Josh Krueger
is his name and he was a local
journalist he's a leftist kind of a
certainly a leftist an activist
and um
but what makes this kind of morbidly
ironic is that he's on the record many
times uh downplaying the violence in his
own City saying it's not a big deal so
here are just some of the tweets that
this guy has sent out previously uh
he says look it's that Lawless land of
liberals in Philly where shootings are
dot dot dot dropping to levels not seen
in years
he said some idiot just said you're more
likely to get shot and killed than die
of covet in Philly to make some
insensitive rhetorical point for his
side folks four times as many
philadelphians have died of covid than
gunshots this year I understand math is
hard but do better
uh another time he says bro speak for
your block mine isn't ruined the city
isn't ruined and just because Larry
krasner keeps winning and landslides
doesn't mean that Philly is a heap of
cinders and Ashes no matter how much
people say like the rest of the country
we are dealing with Optics upticks and
crime so those are just a few of the the
tweets that this guy has sent out
um you know not only downplaying the
violent crime in his own City but kind
of making fun of the people who have
brought it up and have raised concerns
about it and now this guy has been shot
and killed in his own home and there's a
lot we still don't know about the
shooting
we don't know who did it or why
um but again The Morbid irony is
impossible to miss
to have someone who spent years down
playing violent crime in his City fall
victim to it and the point here isn't to
uh that we're not dunking on the guy
we're not finding any joy in his death
it's simply that
reality asserts itself
and the entire leftist project
the whole agenda
is to try and change Reality by
insisting that it's different from what
it really is
reality denial is the core tenet of
leftist ideology
and that's that's what makes leftism
inherently volatile and fragile and
unsustainable in the long run is that
it's built on a foundation of fantasy
of uh of wishes and dreams
which by the way is not the same thing
as saying that leftism has unrealistic
goals okay that's that's that's not what
we're saying
an unrealistic goal
okay if they were just being unrealistic
unrealistic will be to say that we want
to put strategies in place uh that will
turn Philadelphia from a zombie
Wasteland into a livable thriving City
in five years
let's say
that's unrealistic
you look at a city like Philly to try to
turn it around and make it into the kind
of place that a sane person would
actually want to live and you know move
their family to trying to do that in
five years will be unrealistic so that's
an unrealistic goal
but leftism doesn't rise to the to the
level of of unrealistic
like unrealistic would be an improvement
instead it simply denies the existence
of the problem in the first place
they're not coming up with wild naive
um
you know
unworkable solutions for problems
I wish they were doing that that would
be better
no they're just denying that the
problems exist
they're not trying to turn Philadelphia
into a wonderful place in five years
they're simply insisting that
Philadelphia is already a wonderful
place
the crime is not an issue
um
and you can do that but the problem is
that
reality remains what it is
and the thing is that there are elements
of reality
I mean the fundamental elements of
reality can never be changed
fundamental elements like you know
the fact that men are not women that
sort of thing you can't never change
that
but there are aspects of reality that
can be changed it is a reality right now
that Philadelphia is a dangerous
horrible place
technically that can be changed so
that's a re you could change that
reality
but you're not ever going to be able to
do that if you will not acknowledge it
in the first place
and leftism has become so detached from
reality at this point that it cannot
acknowledge anything that is real
and uh
but the reality remains
and it will eventually as I said
reassert itself
whether you like it or not and
oftentimes it will reassert itself you
know when you deny reality and you deny
it you deny it
um you are guaranteeing
that eventually reality will come
knocking on your door and it will say
hey I'm still here this is still real
you can close your eyes all you want but
here it is
you're guaranteeing that will happen
and when it reintroduces itself it's
going to be in a way that uh you really
won't like
and it appears that's what happened uh
with this guy unfortunately
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed